so elon musk uh did i actually lose that
one where is it at here we go elon musk
responding to ben shapiro ben shapiro
said twitter should be uh bench pro
quoting elon musk twitter should be
politically neutral washington post and
every left wing blue check ree
you guys are giving away your game elon
musk said attacks are coming thick and
fast primarily from the left which is no
surprise however i should be clear that
the right will probably probably be a
little unhappy too my goal is to
maximize area under the curve of total
human happiness which means the eighty
percent of people in the middle
i would like to give a shout out to our
good friend shuan head
who in response to a tweet from elon
musk he said for twitter to deserve
public trust it must be politically
neutral which effectively means
upsetting the far right and the far left
equally shun had said elon musk waging
war on both my friend groups
she did respond to his other tweet
saying but those are the least funny
people on this website you need to be
catering to the friendship
i disagree with elon on that i or put it
this way i don't i think what he's
saying is unachievable because you don't
see people on the far right saying that
they want people on the far left banned
but that's the inverse when it comes to
the far left they do want the other side
banned that's the whole issue so
to the greatest extent of this you are
not going to be able to get an equal
level of you know quote unquote anger on
both sides it's just not going to happen
you know unless you're adding some like
arbitrary rules on top of this thing
because essentially um the right
just wants to be left alone number one
or number two wants to be able to have
an even playing field the left doesn't
want an even player elon doesn't
understand
that twitter's policies that he doesn't
like were specifically to make the left
and the right both unhappy
the left was demanding censorship
they're saying twitter is overtly
supporting white supremacists by letting
them say words can you believe that
people misgendered me they should be
banned and twitter said okay
we'll ban some of them the right was
like well they banned them and i'm angry
but i'll stay on the platform because i
can tolerate views i don't like so
twitter said how do we make both sides
happy ban a bunch of conservatives
because conservatives can tolerate in
the left can
if elon musk actually restores free
speech
as he's saying they're primarily coming
from the left that will always be the
case there will be no circumstance where
someone will do something overtly
egregious on the right and the right's
going to be like that's unfair they
should be allowed to do those things
when okay i'm not going to get into it
but when alex jones right was out there
and across every platform he was one of
the biggest shows he just was and if you
ran tracking on this he was getting more
views a day than i think anybody outside
the mainstream media
i saw lots of people on the right i saw
conservatives up and down
attacking him for things
mocking him ridiculing him saying they
disagreed with various takes that he had
on various issues that youtube probably
doesn't want me to get into that's not
my point
i don't remember anybody on the right
ever saying that alex jones should be
taken off the air i don't remember ever
hearing that said once
what if conservatives came out
and said you should not be allowed to
have your own pronouns and twitter
should enact a policy that if you change
your pronouns you'll be banned
then they'd become
pretty extreme
hold on there a minute right now twitter
will ban you if you misgender someone
right so i'm saying what if
conservatives said okay we'll do the
inverse if you use pronouns that are not
in line with your biology we'll ban you
this it feels that is equally as extreme
i know it feels like we're debating who
who should hold the infinity gauntlet
who gets to hold the infinity gauntlet
and everyone knows the answer is no one
they're supposed to break it apart my
point is elon musk is not proposing that
and conservatives are happy
he's saying you can have whatever
pronouns you want but you can't make
someone else say them
and the rights like we can live with
that even though we don't like it and
the left's like no we can't ban them
there's no way that's why you block you
can block whoever you want right but
that makes you right happy but not the
left
difference
and i've i've had to explain this so
many times with people this is the
difference between cancer culture and
boycotts right
completely different things so a boycott
is when one concerted group says we are
no longer going to support a certain
industry organization company or figure
right uh conservatives i believe right
now are generally i don't know if
anyone's actually said this but they're
essentially boycotting disney right over
the groomer situation that whole scandal
and so that's going on as a boycott but
then i'll always see this and people
will say hold on hold on i thought you
said you were against cancel culture no
that's different we're not saying that
they should go out of business we're not
saying that no one can do business with
them that's what canceled culture is is
destroying someone's ability to even
have a livelihood whatsoever it's an
inverted boycott yes whereas boycott
just to reiterate uh reiterate is people
saying we all have decided we're not
going to buy from you the canceled
culture is don't let them sell to anyone
exactly but here's why
the cancel culture is afraid that
without that
the popular sentiment would not be on
their side and when we talk about
conservative versus liberal on the
internet for example in social media i
think part of that is because
there's a control issue where
certain factions which are actually
quite small minority in my view of
people
have been able to use social media in a
controlled way to portray as if
a greater section of the public feels
that way
and i think they're afraid if people
were to actually see what percentage of
the public feels a certain way on
certain topics they would find that many
liberals
side along with conservatives on some
issues and sometimes these are very
fringe fringe discussions and issues
getting a lot of attention because the
social media is controlled when left to
their own devices
this stuff would fall along the fringe
and would not look like it does today
with this controlled conversation
elevating certain issues and views to a
level that's far beyond i think what
they really are yeah the bite swa i
think if you've you've brought this up
is uh
it means white light they have a word
that defines the white left the white
liberals that's to me indicative that
there's a focus on the white left the
white liberal and then you start to see
the manipulation in the social media and
i wonder how involved the the the
creators of the byzawa are in
propagating
here's what happens
here's what happened in in 2014 and 2015
which i was saying when everything was
just open right
twitter at a much smaller user base than
it does today and twitter gained a
massive user base huge influx in 2016
because of trump and because of his
ubiquitous and singular use of twitter
the way he used that platform like no
other person at his level ever had
before right there's always staff tweets
katy perry or um you know barack obama
hillary these are always staff tweets
joe biden right i don't think he knows
what twitter is to an extent or he's
about some website the kids use right
and so
prior to this
um i mean there were really no rules the
idea of someone even being banned on
twitter was almost unthinkable it was
unheard of that people would get
suspended it's certainly not for speech
anything like this but
there was a place on the internet
where crazy people dwelt and the crazy
met with more crazy and they combined to
create exponential crazy and this is a
place
known as the upside down
of tumbler and tumbler essentially
in that time space through things like
gamergate the sjw wars v and then
eventually trump
came onto twitter and essentially
occupied twitter and specifically
occupied the headquarters of twitter and
by maintaining that
to use a cliche high ground
by maintaining the high ground they were
able to impose their will across twitter
and so something i've been saying a lot
lately is what's going on here is the
liberation of twitter from the tumblr
occupation a tumblr occupation tumblr
occupation
yes let's not forget that after
trump won
in that unexpected race which was
unexpected to almost everybody except i
did i was a national journalist who
predicted repeatedly on national tv that
he would win just because i was
listening
outside the beltway to regular people
but once he won
the left admitted including media
matters the propaganda group
that they went and held meetings with
facebook and convinced facebook to take
this new tact which was brand new
to do the fake fact checks the
moderations they didn't call them fake
fact checks of course
but the notion that they would have to
come on and prevent something like this
from happening again
that whole notion was raised in a very
organized fashion shortly after the 2016
election going into 2017. washington
post
i'm uh i'm just browsing twitter so
there's also a time news article where
they talk about fortifying the election
i think it's for 2020. they were
planning it for a year and a half i
think twenty was it was time that
started
right and that was talking about it so
this is the this is the great time
article that that ian's referring to
which was essentially that's that's when
the serial killer has you know conducted
their killings that's the zodiac sending
the cipher to um what was the san
francisco chronicle um you know sending
the letter off to let him know let them
know that they needed credit for it it
was something they needed credit so they
needed to know they needed the world to
know and humans have this innate desire
for credit for
um for their esteem to be stoked so for
that ego power for that e you know
because so many people live off of ego
alone because they're not in touch with
you know as i would say they're not in
touch with god they're not in touch with
the spiritual side of things and so they
live for this world they're very worldly
and they don't understand
that
uh you know this world is ephemeral this
world will you know we'll leave it
behind but anyway the point being is
that article is a confession it's just a
confession we got you well in terms of
controlling political outcomes and
information
that's just the game for them it was it
was brilliant and like you said they
wanted credit for it
well they got it thanks time magazine
for blowing that one off the people are
the secret history of the shadow
campaign that saved yeah the 2020
election so that's what's called the
shadow campaign right thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there is a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm we'll see
you all there
you